Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Office Freakout.
Now, if you know me, you know that I am never one to get angry.
I never lose control.
I never fly off the handle, and I very rarely raise my voice.
So, this game is about... getting angry.
Which is something that I don't understand.
So I thought it would be a good opportunity,
For the sweet, innocent, baby boy that I am,
to try to imagine
...
a little anger!
Why not?
Lemme try my best here.
All right! Here we go! I'mma-- OoOOh!
Welcome to Reboot Computer Repairs! *Arg!*
A cubicle workplace where many employees throw their lives away
doing tediously soul-sucking data entry tasks for the rest of their lives. *dooh*
However, it is currently after work hours
and of course Philbert is still here, slaving away, as demanded by his manager.
Poor Phil!
PHILBERT YOU'RE FIRED
We wish you the best of luck on your future endeavors now clean out your desk!
Uh oh!
Philbert was just fired!
It looks like he has hit his breaking point; Philbert is going crazy!
No!
PHIL NO
CONTROL YOURSELF
Well, it looks like it's time to FINALLY RAGE
PHIL
HERE WE GO
PHIL IT'S NOT WORTH IT
Greetings, employee of business!
Today, we will be going over what to do when fellow employees over come by
I DON'T CARE
Those going through OFFICE FREAKOUT exhibit an undying rage and the ability to break things to the point that they no longer physically exist
Those undergoing an office freakout,
often recollect seeing small colored orbs they compulsively collect.
Click left on the mouse to to punch!
Hold shift to unleash a POWER attack.
Destroyed objects drop point orbs
that will fill your destruction bar.
They have also been observed picking up poor, defensive office supplies.
And using them as weapons!
Or truly placing them GENTLY on the ground.
Right click an object to pick it up.
Use left click to attack.
Right click again to throw.
Or "F" key to drop.
If they continue 'office freaking-out',
They may enter into a RAGE!
Those in a RAGE, will unleash the
FULL, DEVASTATING POTENTIAL OF YOUR AVERAGE...
middle-aged cubicle worker.
This naturally includes the ability to spontaneously generate powerful weapons from thin air.
Destroy things quick enough will fill up your rage bar,
Mark: Uh..
Game: allowing you to enter RAGE mode.
Filling it again will equip your rage weapon.
Fill it a third time to earn twice the points!
Mark: Oh.
If the need of rises, the emergency exit elevator will activate.
Simply find the exit key.
Once you have reached the minimum destruction milestone,
The key will appear on a golden object in the level.
Follow the compass to the golden key once it's appeared on the map.
DESTROY IT to get the key.
Leave the level quickly, and you will be rewarded BONUS points.
Mark: Oh!
Game: Or you can stay and continue your rampage to earn higher scores until time runs out!
But remember! To beat the level, you must have the exit key in order to be successful.
Or you'll be locked in the office for eternity.
Mark: Oh, geez. Game: Remember, employees
every replacement comes from your paycheck.
OH.
who- well, then why would I do tha-
Well, then, why would I do tha-- Oh, I guess I'm fired, so I'm not gonna get any paycheck. So...
oh I guess I'm fired so I'm not gonna-get a paycheck so-
WHATEVER MAN.
okay, ima
Okay, I'mma- OooOO UrrRRgh- I'm gon' get mad!
oOoOoooOOOOOooooOH
mmMMmmmmMMggghhh
IM GON GET MAAAD
WRRAAAAHHHHGGH
RAWR!
RAAAWWR!
IM A- IM AN ANGRY BOIII!!1!
I'm a-- I'm an angry BOY!
IM AN A- IM AN ANGRY MAN!!!1!!1
Get--Get ready! Here comes...
Here comes a thunder!
I'm about to unleash THE BEAST that is ME-st.
How do I... There we...
Got it!
Uh, UUOOARRGH! HAOWUUUUGH!
AH!
Ow.
My hand.
Jesus! Punching things hurt.
Oh, I got one!
An orb went into my body, I feel strange.
I have some serious grievances about the working conditions in this office!
I think that we should have better coffee and more frequent breaks!
Also, I probably shouldn't have been fired
but I'll fight for the other employees now, I suppose...
RAWR! RAWR! I'll probably end up paying for this because I feel bad,
but right now I'm angry!
Oh, you're gonna get it next, David!
I was always upset you had so much food,
and never shared it with me!
That was really mean of you!
You should have been more considerate of other people's feelings.
Uh.
Take these... Terrible airplanes!
WHOOSH
Oh you're gonna get it! WAWHOOSH!
Somehow that happened, I don't know how!
Oh, gosh.
Something tells me I have more power than I realized.
Like when..
Like when Superman first realized that he was actually not...
Human, and an alien... and... probably didn't belong here.
This amount of wanton destruction seems to be irking me a little bit.
I mean, I'm not entirely sure that I should to be...
You know...
DOING this.
Oh god, I'm in a rage!
WOOH! I'm really angry now!
AHH! The computers were always slow,
and getting here was always too heavy in traffic!
It was always like an hour commute, back and forth.
OOOH! IT'S REALLY GETTING ME ANGRY NOW!
I'm gonna unleash a power attack!
WABOOSHKI!
WABASKI!
SHWABOOMKI!
Okay, I.. I did it! I think.
Ha! Dustbuster.
I'm gonna huff this and get ahigh!
So that you guys don't think that I...
I'm-I'm so angry..
HA!
Oh...
Okay.
Hey!
Game: Is that all you've got?!
No.
Oh, my boss is a bit of a dick!
His deadlines are too...
Uh, SHORT! And... And also, he...
He pays me too little.
So little that I don't make any because I'm fired...
Ah- OH!
This seems like it actually might be lethal, so I don't know if I should have this, but...
HA!
UGH
I'll pay for that, I'm sorry.
Oh, geez, I'm sorry.
Oh god.
Oh, that was Suzy's desk.
Aw, shit.
In retrospect, you know...
I feel like I could have talked to a therapist about this,
and it would have been a healthier outlet for all of my unbridled rage.
Uh, I mean, GRR. I'm angry! GRRRR.
Uh- I think at this point I should probably leave..
I-I think I've cleared out enough stuff, I hope this is all tax-deductible
I-I'm just destroying these scissors because it's dangerous for the work environment,
and I want all my fellow co-workers to be safe..!
an-and, feel CARED FOR.
Really wh- all I want, even though i'm-
I seem to be very good at.. stabbing this
in a shanking motion,
I really want everyone to just be happy with their lives.
I mean, "grrrr" oH there's something there
OH
Oh, I- I, I should.. probably report the fact that I've discovered
demon magic to HR, because I'm pretty sure this is irresponsible.
I'M JUST DOING THIS TO TEST IT OUT
OH GOD
I AM SO SORRY.
This is a fire hazard,
I should alert the fire department right away,
but I'm pretty sure if I try to drop this fireball,
it's gonna..
It's gonna burn everybody alive,
and probably- and there's no one here, so
I-I don't wanna risk my own life,
I'm gonna- try to
duh-uh, put it out
Dhaaa, fuck, man.
Ooh god..
Oh, jesus
Oh, god, what have I done??
I don't know, I-I, can I leave??
Oh geez, if I just leave..
Uh..
oH
I'm sorry.
i did it..!!
I did good though, I think I actually felt the anger, uh-
boiling up through me right, right-right behind all of the the remorse I felt,
about this situation
Next level: Sure Lock Security
Narrator: Greetings, Employee of business.
Mark: Hueh.
Office workers such as yourself have many tools of the trade.
Mark: But I was fired.
Staplers, paper cutters, fire extinguishers!
All can be found in your work area!
Please do not misuse what you have been provided.
A staple leaving a stapler can approach speeds of Mach 3
And fire extinguisher foam can be incredibly corrosive!
Certain items can be used as special non-rage weapons,
With devastating effects!
Watch where the sparkling objects, and try throwing them
Or using them with the left-click!
In addition,
-with our recent purchase of Bewm Cola Company™
Every employee will be provided with one free soft drink!
These brand-new flavors developed by Bewm Cola™'s development of weaponized refreshment division,
-are not yet available to the public!
Orbs will be provided just in case any questionable effects you may experience.
Such as suddenly being able to use BOTH hands.
Proceed to activate your perk for a temporary ability;
Soda machines!
12-packs and picture frames may contain refills.
And remember!
Bewm Cola:Always drink responsibly.
At an enhanced rate.
Okay.. That seemed really bizarre, combined with the demon magic,
that I found in the last level,
I'm beginning to wonder what this place is employing people for..
Alright, this time, I-I don't think I was angry enough.
I don't think I channeled the unbridled rage..
So I'mma-- HMGH!
AOHHH!
What was that?!
Was that a skull?!
Oh god!
ohuH, BUH- UH- This book makes ICE PENISES grew from the ground!
This is very irresponsible!
This is supposed to be a family-friendly working environment.
Oh, geez!
HEAUGH!
Oh! They never should have removed Taco Tuesday!
That was obviously the company's best day!
Everyone always looked forward to it and had a great time when it was around.
I know there are budgetary concerns but.. COME ON!
We could have spared a little for the company well being!
ARRRGH!
M-Maybe throwing a harmless paper ball would be okay?
I didn't mean to do that, I'm sorry! What is that?!
Where did I pull this from?!
I mean I know I'm angry but I don't think I'm angry enough to start SHITTING bats!
I-I'm- I'm just- Now that I'm fired, I think I have opportunities in maybe like a professional
sports career? So, I'm just practicing.
If you guys don't mind, I mean- GRR!
I take what I want!
UUUGH
I'm a mean- I'm a bad boy!
I'm- I'm a- I'm a bad boy.
I'm gonna, I'm-I'm-I
I DO CRIMES! OOH! I'M SO BAD! OOH!
When I was in school, I-I skipped out on class to go get ice cream!
YEAH!
IT WAS SO BADASS!
One time, my parents were like, "GO TO BED!" And I was like,
"NOOOO!"
"30 MORE MINUTES, please."
And then I- Then I went to bed cause they said, "No."
AH! Would anybody like some pizza? GRRRR.
Nothing that makes me angrier than pizza!
Sorry.
Okay, I'm gonna-
I'm gonna leave now! I suppose.
Okay, goodbye!
I feel like this has been a good outlet for my aggression!
No one got hurt,
and, uh, no one will know.
Game: You leveled up!
GREAT!
AUGH! I feel angrier!
I'm feeling like this game is a little bit unhealthy.
It's teaching very bad habits for the children each day.
Me being one of those.
I'M 12!
Game: GREETINGS EMPLOYEE OF BUSINESS!
Mark: I'm here! Game: Today, I'd like to talk to you about...
OFFICE SECURITY!
These are gather-round-a-brand Water Coolers!
Sponsored in part by Sure Lock Security.
Feel free to gather round!
And converse with your fellow employees!
In the off chance, any disturbances are detected on a floor,
These specialty coolers will send out security bots to apprehend/eliminate any potential issue!
Raging Worker: You'll never take me alive!
Game: Hahaha, nor do they intend to.
Filling up your destruction bar will also activate enemy spawners.
If an enemy grabs ahold of you, it can result in an INSTANT failure!
Punch him in the face to break free.
Our security coolers have many cool functions.
And we give you a 99% chance that secret listening devices are most CERTAINLY not one.
And remember!
If any employee's feeling a tad peckish, food has been provided on every floor.
Juuust don't forget to fill out a ration requesitition form for those tacos.
Enemy attacks will lower your health. Destroying foods such as tacos or doughnuts, can drop health orbs.
Now you're ready for an exciting and rewarding career!
Have fun, but more importantly,
DON'T EVER STOP WORKING!
Mark: Should I stop- Game: EVER!
Should I stop working, since I've been fired?
Alright, this time I'm gonna REALLY give it to em'.
I'm gon' REALLY UNLEASH my aggression!
auGEH..
THE COMPANY CAMPING TRIP WAS CANCELLED AND
THAT MAKES ME MAAAAAAD!!
AHH! I ONLY GET PAID 1.5 TIMES FOR OVERTIME THIS IS CRAAAAAAP!
UUGH! AHH! THE CHRISTMAS BONUS WAS CUT BY A THIRD THIS YEAR! BAAAAH!
AHH! COMPANY PARKING ISN'T ESTABLISHED CORRECTLY! AHH!
AHH! WE SHOULD GET THREE WEEKS OF PAID VACATION NOT TWO!
AHH! WHY DOESN'T THE HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN COVER DENTAAAAAAL?!?!?
AHHHH!
AHH! NO. IT'S ALWAYS TOO HOT IN THE WINTER AND ALWAYS TOO COLD IN THE SUMMER!
IT'S BULLSHIT!
IT THROWS ME OFF!
AH- Oh no, I- Oh geez.
That's mildly terrifying.
Uh, I'm sorry for my want in destruction. I'll never do it again.
uuuUUUuuuUHH.
aH! Oh geez I'm sorry sir. I'm sorry, have a doughnut!
UH.
Uh.
I think he's taking a nap. I can see he's still breathing.
Would you also like a doughnut sir?
Doughnut? Doughnut? Doughnut?
Oh geez. Oh geez. Oh geez. Oh GEEZ.
Ah.
Oh.
AH!
I'm gonna get angry at you guys too.
Back off! I got a chair!
Heh!
Oh- You don' t want- Whole chair!
Up your butt?!
Oh, gee- AH! I'm sorry! I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
You know sometimes, I don't remember that there are other employees in here, and
I should really considerate of other people's feelings at this juncture in time.
UUUUUAGH.
Please get out of the wa- Oh, that's not good.
Oh! I've been- Ah! No! Ah, god.
I confessed everything! I'm a victim of the system!
No I had to lie. I chose this path and I'm very sorry for what I've done. (Sure mark)
DON' T TELL MY MOM!
REALLY, I'M NOT A BAD BOY.
I'm a GOOD boy.
I'm a good boy!
This game is mean, and it's..
It's..
It's- It's for people who are also mean!
Okay.
I- I feel alright now.
I feel like I vented some frustration.
And.. And this is a healthy way to do it because it's digital
and it's not actually real, so no one actually gets hurt.
Bu- But if you have any..
any HARSH feelings out there, another good outlet is to YELL in the comments randomly,
and at everyone that passes by no matter what they did or what they're trying to do.
Just yell uncontrollably at them.
Wait..
NOOOO!
But anyway, that was Office Freakout.
Hopefully you enjoyed that. I feel..
Destressed now.
I feel like I could..
You know, actually BREAK some office equipment in half.
But I think I'll be okay, I'll hold in my aggression.
If I ever have to work a cubicle job again,
which I have in the past,
["Crazy La Paint" initialized]
I'd probably do the same damn thing.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you in the NEXT video! Buh-bye! :D
[MiniMusicMan: "Crazy La Paint" intensifies]
^w^